We're on problem 14.
And it asks us what is the
solution to the inequality x
minus 5 is greater than 14?
Well, to do this, this
is just like solving
any equality or equation.
What we do to one side, we have
to do the other side.
And we want to get rid of this
minus 5, and the best way to
get rid of a minus 5 is to add
5, so lets add 5 to both sides
of this equation.
So 5 plus and then a plus 5.
And then a 5 plus a
minus 5, that's 0.
That's why we added the
5 in the first place.
So we're just left with
an x on that side.
We get x is greater than
14 plus 5, which is 19.
That's choice B.
Problem 15.
The lengths of the sides
of a triangle are--
so we have a triangle.
They tell us the lengths of the
sides are y, y plus 1, and
7 centimeters.
They also tell us the perimeter
is 56 centimeters.
The perimeter is equal
to 56 centimeters.
What is the value of y?
So the perimeter of any shape is
just the sum of the sides.
So y plus y plus 1 plus 7.
That's the distance around
the triangle.
And that is equal to
the perimeter,
which is equal to 56.
Let's see, we get y plus y is
2y, plus 1 plus 7 is 8, is
equal to 56, so you get 2y
is equal to what is that?
56.
So if we subtract 8 from both
sides of this equation, on the
left-hand side, we
just get 2y.
On the right-hand side,
56 minus 8, that's 48.
Divide both sides by 2 and
you get y is equal to 24.
And that is choice A.
Problem 16.
Now what do they
want us to do?
All right, I think this is one
I should copy and paste.
OK, now they're telling us--
let me pick a good color.
Which number serves as a
counterexample to the
statement below?
So, a counterexample, an example
that shows that this
isn't always true.
So the statement is all
positive integers are
divisible by 2 or 3.
So we just have to find a
positive integer that is not
divisible by 2 or 3,
by neither 2 nor 3.
Well, 100 is divisible
by 2, right?
So that just verifies or it's
just another example of a
positive integer that's
divisible by one of these two,
so it's not choice A.
It's not a counterexample.
57, It's not divisible by 2,
but it is divisible by 3.
19 times 3 is 57.
So it's not choice B.
57 is another positive integer
that's divisible by 2 or 3.
It's divisible by 3,
so it's not that.
30's divisible by both, so
that's definitely not a
counterexample.
But here we have 25.
It's a positive integer and it
is neither divisible by 2 nor
3, so it disproves
the statement.
So it is a counterexample.
And so the answer is D.
Problem 17.
Let me copy and paste
this one.
Copied it.
Pasted it.
All right.
What is the conclusion of the
statement in the box below?
OK, they say if x squared
is equal to 4.
So if we know that x squared is
equal to 4, then we know,
and we know this from algebra,
we could have solved it, that
x is equal to minus 2 or 2.
All right, so what is the
conclusion of the statement in
the box below?
Oh, OK.
I think I'm reading
this too much.
This is the condition and
this is the conclusion.
They're saying if this
has happened,
then we conclude that.
So they're actually just
asking us to label it.
This is the conclusion.
Then x is equal to
minus 2 or 2.
I don't like that question
so much.
My reaction was, OK, if this is
the whole statement, what
can I conclude from it?
And there's not a lot that I
could conclude from it unless
they told me that this
indeed was true.
But anyway, I don't want
to get too complicated.
They're just saying that if
this is true, then we can
conclude this.
And they're actually just saying
what is the conclusion?
So what part of this statement
can we label as the
conclusion?
Well, that's the conclusion,
so that's choice D.
I didn't like that.
That was more meaning
of words than math.
But anyway, problem 18.
All right, let me copy and
paste this one, too.
Which of the following
is a valid
conclusion to the statement?
OK.
You see, now if a student is a
high school band member, then
the student is a
good musician.
So if you're in the high school
band, high school band
member, then you're going
to be a good musician.
That's what this says.
And if you compare this
to the last question,
that could be confusing.
Because a valid conclusion--
so once again, here they're
giving us a statement and they
want us to come to some
conclusion.
They might have said
what is the
conclusion of this statement?
And then you would have
said, oh, the
student is a good musician.
But that's not what
they're asking.
They're saying, OK, if this
whole thing is a statement, if
we know that this whole thing
is true, if they're in the
high school band, then they're
a good musician, which I kind
of wrote in shorthand here.
They're asking, OK, if we know
that to be true, which of
these statements can we
conclude from that?
Statement A says, all
good musicians are
high school band members.
Well, that doesn't
tell us that.
It doesn't say that all good
musicians-- the good musicians
could be this circle and the
high school band members would
be a subset of it.
High school band, and this
could be good musicians.
So right, all high school band
members are good musicians,
but there could be people out
here who are good musicians
who aren't high school
band members.
So it's not choice A.
A student is a high school
band member.
Well, no.
High school band members, they
didn't tell us that all of the
students are high school band
members or the high school
band is comprised of all
of the students.
The student body might
be like this circle.
Some of them might be in
the high school band.
Some of them aren't and
are good musicians.
aren't good musicians.
So, I mean, you don't know
whether someone is a high
school band member just
by being a student.
All students are
good musicians.
Once again, you know, this
could be an example.
There could be people out here
who are students, the yellow
could be students.
There could be people
who are students
who aren't good musicians.
This statement doesn't in
any way constrain that.
So let's get rid of that.
All high school band members
are good musicians.
Well, let's look at
this Venn diagram.
I mean, that's almost like
a restating of what they
already told us.
All high school band members
have to be good musicians
because they told us, if you're
in the high school
band, then you're
a good musician.
So it's almost like repeating
the same statement twice, but
the answer is D.
Problem 19.
Let me erase this one.
This looks like another
one that I'm going to
have to copy and paste.
OK, copied it.
OK, let me do a dark color.
The chart below shows an
expression evaluated for four
different values of x.
When x is equal to 1, x squared
plus x plus 5, right.
1 plus 1 plus 5 is 7.
When x is equal to 2, then 2
squared plus 2 plus 5 is 11.
Fair enough.
Josiah or Hosiah, I don't know
how to pronounce that,
concluded that for all positive
values of x, x
squared plus x plus 5 produces
a prime number.
Which value of x serves as
a counterexample to prove
Josiah's conclusion false?
So a counterexamples says-- he
says that whenever I put any
positive number here, I get
a prime number here.
We have to say which one
proves him false?
If you put 5 there, what is-- 5
squared is 25 plus 5 plus 5,
and what is that equal to?
That's equal to 35.
So that's a counterexample
right there.
If x is equal to 5, I produce
35, which is not a prime
number, not prime.
So clearly, his statement, his
conclusion, was incorrect,
that when you put a positive
number here, it doesn't always
produce a prime number.
That was his conclusion.
This one isn't prime.
So statement A is a
counterexample, or the number
5 is a counterexample here.
Next problem, problem 20.
OK, this is one of those where
we have to pinpoint the
incorrect step.
John's solution to an equation
is given below.
For which step of real numbers
did-- oh, which property of
real numbers did John
use for step 2?
OK, so we don't even have
to look at step 1.
We just have to say,
OK, how did he get
from there to there?
So when you look at this, when
you say x plus 2 times x plus
3 is equal to 0, you're saying
some number x plus 2 times
some other number x plus
3 is equal to 0.
So that's like saying some
number times some other number
is equal to 0.
So that means that one of those
numbers or both of them
have to be equal
to zero, right?
Because the only way to get
zero is if one of these or
both of these have to
be equal to zero.
And that's where he gets this
conclusion that either x plus
2 has to be 0 or
x plus 3 is 0.
They're both zero.
So let's see how they--
what do they call it?
Multiplication property
of equality.
I don't even know
what that means.
Zero property of
multiplication?
This seems like the closest
one for me so far.
That anything times zero is zero
Or for two things to be
multiplied to equal zero,
at least one of
them has to be zero.
And that's what this
is right here.
Commutative property
of multiplication?
No, that's not it.
Distributive property of
multiplication over addition?
No, we're not doing anything
like that.
If we went from this step
to that step where we're
multiplying it, that might
have been, because you're
really just doing the
distributive property, but I
don't want to confuse you.
Yeah, we're just saying that
if two numbers when you
multiply them equal zero,
one of them have
to be equal to zero.
And I guess the label for that
is the zero product property
of multiplication.
Anyway, see you in
the next video.